I have a theory about you and Asians you
were raised by them
yes who the first was Sunni and Ted
Sunni Sunni Ted was the bar manager at
the club yeah this was like in the 70s
yeah and then and and Sunni was married
to Ted and they were both and I and
they're both Thai and they lived at my
mom's house downstairs so Ted would be
the bar manager he'd go to the club and
Sunni she went to USC and she was like
trying to get a doctor's degree or some
yeah yeah I mean and she used to take me
to school
oh she would make me like hot pepper
beef in Tupperware Ron did always not
always liked as a kid running around my
house and she always like she never
cooked in the kitchen she felt cuz she
was like a housekeeper she didn't want
to go in the kitchen area yeah so she
brought all like the hot hot pate hot
pans and in the you know the cooking
stuff yeah inside her bedroom so I would
smell the hot pepper beef and I'd
[ __ ] go in the bedroom and she'd have
sticky rice it was the stickiest rice I
was [ __ ] obsessed oh my god and I'd
go in there and she'd make me a ball and
I sit there with her and she had like
[ __ ] dongs and [ __ ] in there but you
know like little like dogs because even
still the bar staff up until a couple of
years ago was a lot of Thai still I saw
what was his name the guy that was there
for years
there was Tony mmm right there's a Huck
Huck I saw him in Thailand
oh you saw Huck in Thailand yeah yes
hilarious you guys had a meal or just
right oh that's so nice I love that like
a restaurant out there oh wow I love
that I can Phuket Wow but you didn't
have a traditional opera here man it
must been crazy with Kinison babysitting
you
he was never babysitting me the way it
was is what I thought the bull might say
yeah no it was [ __ ] yeah
no he it was my parents divorced when I
was three and then I liked the phones
going off in here that's good the phones
on top of the back so maybe there'll be
some Gong's know it was like jack Perdue
Dave Tyree Mike binder Argos and Wilson
Mitchell Walters Allen Stevens those are
the guys that really babysit me Louis
Bromfield Wow she babysat me for real
yeah I think Kennison just kind of took
me under his wing because when I first
started when I was like 17 18 years old
Sam was at the Westwood Comedy Store and
he was a doorman there and my mom used
to put him on last yeah and Sam used to
go on at [ __ ] 2:00 a.m. and he would
get get the stool there be a stool on
the [ __ ] chair on the stage and you'd
scream out of my house is my house
uh-uh-uh
he'd take the stool and you throw it at
the the six people that were in the
audience like UCLA kids nits scamper off
and then he'd come backstage and I'd be
like shaking my head and I'd be cleaning
up and I give him food and then I leave
the door open
the back door open and let him sleep on
the stage was LeBeau back there - yeah
it was LeBeau was like it was Joey
Gaynor it was Freddie asparagus I love
those guys it was you know it was
asparagus a real guys yeah you ever see
three amigos oh yeah every amigos he was
the bartender yeah that Mexican Big Bob
bartender that's ready asparagus yeah
yeah those are the guys that babysat me
my mom dated this guy Steve Landsberg
Steve Landsberg was on this show and the
70s called Barney Miller Barney Miller
was like the biggest sitcom in the world
if you google Barney Miller it was like
the big it was like police officers was
a comedy and it was like I forgot who
was the big there was a Korean dude on
it though I know that yes there was a
Korean dude a black guy yeah and I ate
Bogota was on Dave Devoto yeah yeah and
Steve Landsberg was on it and then that
was like my mom would shoes that are
happiest she dated this guy Steve
Landsberg yeah which she the saddest
when she dated Argus um no she was happy
when she dated Argus she just didn't
like that Argus was a drug addict yeah I
didn't mean but she believed in him yeah
you and I mean and it's a shame because
I feel really bad because Argus is a
great guy and he was an addict so he
never made it and I feel really bad
because like because this cocaine
problem and alcohol yeah yeah
if you don't know Argus Hamilton still
plays the Comedy Store he's got to be 70
years old by now yeah well he always
says he's 59 which is I'm a baby boomer
and I'm 59 years old it's like oh my god
but he still plays the room he opens
still great yeah but there is a part of
me that just feels bad for him no you
shouldn't he's alive yeah you know I
mean yeah I mean no but you know what I
mean for real like he's been he'd been
through a lot like yeah he like people
hear about Sam Kinison being a drug
addict and cokehead and all that [ __ ]
Argus was way worse way worse dude I
don't like peel him away from my mom
dude like you abuse yeah for sure like
he used to [ __ ] come home my mom
would have her jag and she would come
home and and I would you know I guess
leave me alone you're [ __ ] drunk get
out of here go home
nomid see I'm staying here and then like
one time I had a [ __ ] call the cops
on him you know I mean and like yeah it
was bad and then this was this was
[ __ ] up dude like I had to call the
cops on him and then I go downstairs and
the cops were there and then and then
what happened was as they say that the
cops I'm like this guy's [ __ ] with my
mom and then my mom was like my mom was
like oh it's fine don't worry about it's
okay and then the cops would leave and
the August would corner me yeah and then
he'd be like Oh real funny funny man
calling the police on me now what are
you gonna do anyone that's [ __ ] super
nice is super [ __ ] nuts yeah yeah
yeah you're right mom yeah I know the
moan
[Laughter]
right there is a hidden thing there yeah
yeah I mean Simone is the best guy in
the world but he's also not silly oh
yeah he's not is this rumor true then
when Sam Kinison
I heard he became more he got more spots
because he one time saved your mom from
from Argus I don't know if that's why I
know that my mom is Sam loved each other
to death well they did yeah of course
yeah mom loved Sam yeah Sam loved my mom
because he developed at the store yeah
and she developed him just like she
developed arsenio or Rosanna or any of
them you know she loves Sam Sam was like
her her own son you know I mean you just
think the names that came out of your
[ __ ] Club is insane everyone yeah you
know and that's the thing it's like I
want there now and in like yeah you talk
about how great the businesses yeah and
it is it's making more money now than
like ever or or since when it was in the
heyday yeah I gonna day but comedy back
then you know like I watched guys I'm in
the back I watched mark Meyer and I
watched these guys and I talked about
this Sun row I think I talked about on
Rogen I forgot what podcast I talked
about or like like I watch Eliza I watch
you know everyone and they're all they
all kill but they're not like it was
they are not like [ __ ] Eddie Murphy
and [ __ ] Pryor in Kennison the vibe
was a hundred percent different you know
and I mean even Chappelle and Chris Rock
like are like that probably the biggest
comics in the world nothing compared to
[ __ ] how it was because like when
you're in the back dude and I would
sometimes I would walk Richard to the
stage yeah because like I would see him
I was so obsessed with them but I was
also was my mom's Club yeah I love me
and every time I'd see him he'd give me
a hug and say what's up and are always
rush and get him a drink you know I mean
I get him a soda or alcohol or gin or
whatever he wanted and not put him there
like people away from him cuz he had to
get his head together it was he's like
[ __ ] Jesus dude yeah and it sit on
the belly room stairs yeah they're right
sit there and I'd be like back off back
off and I tell my mom I like Mom
Richards here and she would freak out
she would go over there and give him a
hug and
kiss everyone leave them alone and then
I'd kind of like peek in the room to see
what it up yeah I'm like okay dude we're
ready and I'd [ __ ] walk them in and
then walk them up in this - oh are you
oh my gosh yeah yeah I'd walk them in
there and I welcome and I'd be in the
back booth there and he would [ __ ]
come on someone say ladies and gentleman
Richard Pryor people I swear to God
which [ __ ] stand up and [ __ ] just
they were like oh my god it was like
Jesus was walking in yeah
it wasn't you know name me like you know
it was like insanity walk up on stage
and people couldn't believe Richard
Pryor was on the stage but I think that
has a lot to do with now in the age of
the Internet they're just anyone can get
notoriety through their YouTube channel
this and that back then you had to be
the best to get on TV and whatnot it was
harder to make it so when you did make
it the whole world knew who you were
like you know back in the day when they
said I would do I did Johnny Carson once
and I became an overnight
I mean Candis Thompson who you just met
just did the [ __ ] Tonight Show a
couple of months ago and no one knows
where the [ __ ] she is yeah it's harder
yeah and then I do Rogen and everyone
talks about it I know it's a Grogan's
podcast is like the biggest in the world
tonight [ __ ] John it's bigger than
you know anything anything yeah and
that's just the way it is but my point
is is Richard Pryor was just funnier
than anyone you know so so you know it's
like like I love Kris and I love
Chappelle and they're [ __ ] they're
both the best yeah but Richard was
Richard
[Music]